professor I couldn't interview the
famous cédric Villani and not ask about
the spider can I ask about the spider
anyone who's seen photos of you will see
this spider you wear it very often do
you talk about where it comes from you
have a few different ones don't you why
do you wear a spider have a lot of them
but they never explained why it mean
well numberphile show you some of my
best specimens special cases yeah I have
to protect them this is from Nyjah was
made by 8 Warrick artists this is a cone
aligner the stone they say both from a
Bulgarian seller this one comes from
Uruguay this one that one they were made
for me
this one also was made for me it's from
Morocco
this is Berber art this one is from
Eastern Europe
amber here are some sick ones that I
will have to take to reparation this was
at the hospital that one from Macedonia
oh that one from Argentina they will go
into surgery but the reason for the
spider this is an unanswered question I
think you will not get your answer how
many times are you asked about it about
every day so since I started wearing it
10 years ago it's been a lot of times
several thousand times how many people
know the answer
Oh less than that see how much it falls
and the photo itself also it reminds
some organic form you know like some
kind of salad all right you know a
thousand people are gonna write comments
under the video about why they think